mais il se trouve que là j'ai eu
l'occasion
de prolonger cet engagement parce que le
programme que porte jean luc mélenchon
est un programme inédit pour moi et
qu'il est absolument indispensable et
nécessaire par rapport aux urgences que
je viens de vous décrire et je voudrais
dire que j'ai été assez choqués de ce
que je viens d'entendre de la part de
charles consignes et là je vais parler
non pas en tant que militant écologiste
non en tant que journalistes
mais c'est expliqué quand est-ce que
j'ai commencé à songer sérieusement à
voter pour jean luc mélenchon même si je
les parts pour 2017 pour parce que
j'attendais encore d'être convaincu je
pense que que la pensée de jean luc
mélenchon là pour le problème qui
portait encore mûri s'est bonifié
gérant j'ai reçu à plusieurs reprises
jean luc mélenchon sur des plateaux et
un jour il est venu présenter un livre
dans on n'est pas couché j'ai lu ce
livre je les ai toujours aidé à vitesse
normale les stadiers qui parlait
d'écologie justement de planification
écologique qui parlait de la mer
et je me suis dit c'est dingue ça fait
des années que fait ce travail je n'ai
jamais lu un livre aussi documenté aussi
précis et aussi ouvert sur l'avenir de
la part d'un homme politique et c'est là
je me suis dit qu'il y avait peut-être
des incompréhensions sur qui était qui
et jean luc mélenchon est choisi dès
qu'il porte et là j'ai commencé à m'y
intéresser très fortement et donc je
suis assez ennuyé de ce que j'ai entendu
de la part de charles concilie parce que
je pense que il fait une énorme erreur
lorsqu'il parle de pas retenu des mots
mais de quelques du show du spectacle de
l'égoïsme de l'égocentrisme
j'ai pas juger la psychologie de jean
luc mélenchon c'est pas mon propos ce
que je sais c'est que son programme et
je vous dis en tant que journaliste même
pas en tant que militant et le plus
sérieux le plus travaillé qui a
aujourd'hui comme offre politique
d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça et c'est aussi le plus le
plus réaliste pour ça pour ça que vous
l'avez rejoint oui et programme est
réaliste et le plus réaliste sur ce
qu'on a dit tout à l'heure mais bien sûr
ses terres que ce sont vous savez vous
connaissez les l'idée de l'idée de
l'utopie inversée dit le moof l'idée de
lutte en épi oui c'est que c'est counter
sanders qui nous parle des utopistes
l'inversé ceux qui croient que le
système dans quelles eaux vit
aujourd'hui va extrêmement bien et qu'on
croit que tous mais nous avons mis en
place et bien va vraiment sur la bonne
route et en revanche ceux qui sont
réalistes aujourd'hui sont taxés
d'utopistes parce qu'il proposait un des
choses qui nous semble irréalisable
alors que c'est tout l inverse quand
jean-luc mélenchon propose la réduction
du temps de travail aujourd'hui c'est un
indispensable lorsqu'il propose 2 par
exemple effectivement en ce concerne
l'alimentation une révolution
alimentaire ont réduit considérablement
la part des protéines animales c'est ce
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui si on prend
chacune des propositions on voit qu'il
ya un modèle cohérent et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est le seul aujourd'hui à
nous proposer une vision nouvelle du
monde alors pourquoi pas yannick jadot
fait manche l'américain écologistes et
bien tout simplement parce que il n'ya
pas dans le programme de yannick jadot
la radicalité nécessaire qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui dans prime de jean luc
mélenchon parce que les verts esi depuis
des années ça pas très bien où sont
savent pas sur quel pied danser ils
savent pas s'ils sont libéraux
antilibéraux s'ils remettent en cause le
système s'il lamente simplement aux
marges mais on n'en est plus là
aujourd'hui la seule écologie possible
c'est une écologie de rupture et donc je
tiens à dire aussi d'ailleurs que je
n'ai pas rejoint jean luc mélenchon tout
seul il ya d'autres militants
écologistes qui ont rejoint jean luc
mélenchon elle m'a dufour par exemple
des amis de la terre
l'air le jeune démarche claire le jeune
démarches pour le climat et il y a aussi
le mouvement que j'ai créée qui
s'agrègeront way qui s'appelle la
révolution écologique pour l'union je
suis pas venu tout seul c'est à dire que
le mouvement que j'ai créée et qu'elle
un mouvement d'écologie de rupture
antispécistes radical a jugé dans son
ensemble qu'aujourd'hui il fallait
s'engager avec le programme de jean luc
mélenchon alors je veux pas faire
tourner parce que j'aurais entendu jean
luc chemin 8,6 à relais un peu de ces
propositions mais je voudrais juste te
dire que parmi les choses qui m'ont
particulièrement séduite dans le
discours de jean-luc sait que c'est le
seul aujourd'hui à porter le discours
qu'il porte sur les droits des animaux
qui est un sujet que je moi évidemment
me tient particulièrement à coeur et il
ya une figure pour cela je pense qu'il
explique et qui crée la jonction entre
jean luc et moi c'est louise michel
figure de l'anarchie
qui explique qu'elle a écrit des pages
magnifiques sur les animaux sur la
défense des animaux et on explique que
son combat pour les plus faibles pour
les opprimés et figure de la commune
aussi louise michel je rappelle et bien
il est né dans le l'empathie qu'elle a
senti tout jeune tout petit pour les
animaux sont maltraités pour elle l a
compris que tout était lié le combat
social le combat pour les animaux mais
également aussi une combat féministe
c'était aussi une féministe ce sont les
mêmes logiciels de pensée qui nous
dirigent alors sur ce sujet précisément
j'aimerais vous entendre jean luc parce
que moi je me souviens d'une
intervention
là aussi ça fait partie de moi qui m'ont
décidé à à mieux écouter jean luc une
intervention à l'assemblée nationale sur
les rapports nouveaux que nous devons
établir avec nos congénères nos cousins
nos frères les animaux non humains alors
jean-luc déjà
aymeric caron donc nous a rejoint sait
si c'est une bonne nouvelle pour vous ah
bah oui mais ce que j'aime dans ce
qu'ils lâchent et c'est la démarche
enfin
aymeric caron il ne renonce à rien de
son propre programme
cas pas le mien
mais il a retrouvé dans mon programme
une part du chien qui lui paraissaient
suffisantes pour que allait donner le
coup de main et pas être la secte qui
tente qu'elle n'a pas retrouvé tous ses
signes cabalistiques
refuse d'aider et je trouve que c'est un
exemple qui pourrait donner à d'autres
il n'y a pas besoin qu'on soit d'accord
à 100% il ya une trame générale il ya un
esprit j'ai résumé dans une formule tout
à l'heure j'admets qu elle est abstraite
mais quand on y réfléchit à louplande
piste harmonie des êtres humains entre
eux pas d'inégalité pas de domination
pas de discrimination et avec la nature
et je dois vous dire que je suis pas né
dans cette tradition politique faut que
vous sachiez monsieur ne s'était pas
notre truc comme j'avais 20 ans l'idée
c'était on développe les forces
productives et le progrès va venir
mécaniquement des on croyait ça dur
comme fer
et on s'est pas rendu compte de ce qu'on
était en train de cautionner le
productivisme qui avait lieu non
seulement dans les pays capitalistes
mais aussi dans les pays socialistes qui
se disait socialiste puisque moi j'ai
jamais adhéré à l'idée qu'ils étaient
socialistes puisque y avait pas de
démocratie
alors voilà après ça c'est le poids
important beaucoup peuvent faire comme
lui et puis moi j'ai essayé si vous
voulez ne pas m'en tenir à jeu 2-3
banalité j'ai réfléchi avec les autres
avec des gars comme lui qui
m'interpellait qui me secouer et je me
dis mais moi je sais que je supporte pas
de voir martyriser les animaux il suffit
pas de mes sentiments je les partage
avec plein de gens compris de gens ne
font pas d'accord avec mon programme
compris des gens qui sont des
adversaires politiques ils peuvent dire
ah mais moi là dessus on s'entend on
n'est pas d'accord pour martyriser les
animaux mais qu'est ce qui fait que nous
pouvons les traités à égalité de dignité
pourquoi nous les êtres humains et je
vois là j'ai bossé pour réfléchir à ça
et je me suis dit voilà la raison la
raison c'est que dans l'ordre du vivant
nous sommes ceux qui sont dotés de la
capacité la plus grande à comprendre et
à être conscients et dès lors plus on
est conscient plus on est responsable de
ce qui le sont moins